[Musique]
vous ne savez jamais quand vous tombez
sur quelqu'un qui va changer votre vie
[Musique]
c'est juste que je m'attendais pas à
cette boule de poils se connaissent et
chats c'est un chien errant géniaux
convaincant de nous suivre à la sortie
des pâleurs par la commande cet appel
alors d'où tu viens mon pote
il vient d'une poubelle qu'est ce qu'on
va faire avec maman elle va être folle
furieuse oui c'est pour ça qu'on va rien
me dire
en attendant il va rester dans notre
choix salut aliments salut maman la
meilleure ma main de toutes les mamans
dans tout le monde entier c'est quoi la
bêtise est la dure ou ici on la plaine
michael jordan et le nom le plus débile
pour un chèque jamais entendu benjamin
conclave un chien pourquoi pas des nues
c'est vrai qu'il a tout l'air d'un benji
il a l'air vieux et jeunes en même temps
[Musique]
carter mais c'est quoi ça c'est un chien
en peluche et c'est un chat ni m y suis
bon j'ai compris j'ai compris tout
mignon mais tuer un chien c'est pas un
truc c'est benji que j'ai baptisé chez
moi on fait pas en fait
franck et
qu'est ce qui s'est passé benji se
montrant forgé un suspect qui s'enfuit
fois le bras à peu près 10 kg à quatre
pattes non pas spécialement
[Musique]
ces options
nos enfants ont le coeur qui déborde
d'amour
j'y trouve une nouvelle famille sur
netflix
[Musique]